what's difference between the the the
now child breastfeeding versus the child
who is relying on the nutrients inside
the body
yeah um
well it's
the the hu the person that uh
had the child inside their body is
[Music]
where am i going
so after news broke uh from the leak
that the supreme court will allegedly
overturn roe v wade
of course the media jumped on it and
this happened if the court
overturns roe v wade it will be a direct
assault on freedom 69 of americans say
they do not want the court to overturn
versus roe v wade if this is issued over
20 states there's a trigger where
abortion will automatically be banned i
am just i cannot tell you the outrage i
feel at this decision the republicans
have been working toward this day for
decades women will die
[Music]
what are the next things that are going
to be attacked
i'm killing the baby okay that seems bad
but that could be because most americans
don't actually know what the overturning
of roe v wade
really means so contrary to gotcha
journalism with man in the street we
decided to uh
just go and talk with people and find
out
actually if you guys do have a couple
minutes we're just asking have you been
fi have you been following the roby wade
overturning
what is it the uh the federal
supreme court the abortion law yeah oh
yeah okay so about that yeah do you mind
if asking we're just kind of getting a
feel for everybody where they line up on
this what what do you think about it
it's a horse
so roby wade yeah it's the supreme court
there was a leak we're assuming it's
true it seems like it's true they're
going to be overturning roe v wade
which is like they're going to be
letting people aboard the chart
so this is actually a good question and
this isn't because a lot of people
didn't really understand this a lot of
people think that overturning roe v wade
means there'll be a federal ban on
abortion yeah it just means that it'll
go back to the states where states can
make their own laws if they want to have
restrictions and if states don't want to
have restrictions they don't i think
that's true bro i think it should be a
female decision because it's her body
it's you know
so if the man was carrying the baby i
feel like he'll be up to the man because
he's the woman you know god has this
woman gets to carry the baby didn't she
hurt what about the the law though of
like supreme court putting it back to
the states does that seem you can't put
laws on people's bodies and people's
[ __ ] off
i assume you know that guy no no no no
no
no
[Music]
yeah
so you don't think that states should be
allowed to have restrictions on them no
i don't think the federal order states
should have it i think it should be up
to the to the parents you know it's a
parental parental name put on the a's
depending on age you think it should be
restrictions another way of controlling
yeah yeah controlling like it's only
what we do basically you know so you say
it's a you think it's a good thing to
control the population
it depends on what they're doing because
it seemed like like back in the days
playing business all in like black
people's neighborhoods yeah well do you
know planned parenthood margaret sanger
was they set up shop aboard these
abortion clinics in black neighborhoods
because she wanted to abort more black
babies yeah so they can have the race
going on right
you know so that's a but that's a bad
thing if you're saying that yeah that
maybe does that maybe make you think
about abortion
i feel like i feel like i feel like this
right we in america right at the end of
the day right yeah you're supposed to be
like freedom you see me yeah you know
so then today why you know i'm saying we
don't have the freedom to do
you know what we want to do it's not
really like you know i mean i understand
but can you not so the other side of the
argument that people have is i'm curious
because he said woman so he's basically
this is what i'm saying he wants to punt
he wants to go to you know have her
answer he want to piss you off yeah yeah
but you understand the other side of the
argument is if someone you know
scientists and biologists say well it's
not really that person's body if it's a
baby in their body that's why for
example like texas their limitation is a
heartbeat once there's a separate
heartbeat they're saying you can't have
an abortion yeah okay does that make
sense that makes a lot of sense because
this in the heartbeat didn't i think he
said that's not murder right yeah
so then maybe you would so you think
texas should be allowed to place a
limitation like at a heartbeat maybe how
the heartbeat seemed like
everybody have one
yeah a specification
of once it gets to a certain standard
okay stage
you should be able to and should be able
not to would you definitely yeah one
thing has a heartbeat i don't think okay
so you said so this is your is it your
youtuber together yeah so you have three
kids
you got four kids so you did the
ultrasound yeah and i just had my first
twins so you remember that first of all
yeah congratulations they're tough yeah
by the way anyone who tells you that
boys and girls aren't different
go and have one boy and one girl twin
you know she's she starts talking really
young and she's no verbal he's just
but then he's just jumping and running
oh yeah
level yeah yeah yeah it's not even close
one more action
oh yeah they're both that you know all
the riches
yeah all the rich white liberals are
trying to be like ah it's all society
i'm like no no i have not taught
anything of these twins literally
she grabs something she tries to put it
in her mouth he grabs something and
tries to hit you with it yeah that's
right what he does
yeah exactly exactly so so you remember
that first ultrasound where you saw the
heartbeat yeah
so
you you would say that's at that point
that's a lot like oh guys okay
well then look and that's so that's kind
of why i was having this conversation
because the supreme court
before this ruling now overturning roe v
wade texas wouldn't have had the right
to say okay after a heartbeat you can't
have an abortion
so now the overturning of roe v wade
means texas can't have that ball
so that seems like something that yeah
this is the only thing man texas is
always like that they don't want it well
they couldn't though it used to be it
was technically illegal for texas to do
that yeah they're becoming more liberal
but a heart so we would
see i think that's a good place to find
common ground in other words if people
who are abortion all the way up to nine
months and being a mother i would assume
you're like that's ridiculous yeah then
you know some people think no abortions
but a heartbeat good place to start yeah
all right
i think that's a lot of people in the
country you know but unfortunately you
see the protests you see the media
making it seem like something it isn't
and people go nuts yeah it seems like a
lot of people are kind of like you in a
sliding scale
people just don't know what they want
yeah what it is people don't know what
they want yeah because a heartbeat is
you know you can start hearing it now
it's six weeks but certainly ten weeks
yeah because yeah i remember seeing that
little heart be like oh my gosh as i
don't know about you as a dad but for me
i was just paranoid or i'm like all
right just make sure she doesn't take
any stairs and falls down then like
because we can't do anything yeah but
he's not in us we're just like just
don't do anything that could hurt the
baby
keep her in a bubble yeah that's exactly
like a bubble wipe all right well thank
you guys i appreciate it thanks for
tuning in on that too
what's your name by the way sarah sarah
nice to meet you sir what's your name
sierra sierra sierra and sarah i'll try
and get us straight so uh but we're just
asking people today have you been
following sort of the you know the
overturn the leak of the alleged
overturning of robbie wade uh i i'm not
really like falling like
completely
okay and you nodded your head yet i mean
i followed it for well not i the leak is
horrible but i followed like you know
the abortion controversy for a while
i've had my stance on like you know i
think it's
we should have saved abortions okay
so what do you what do you think about
the robbie wade you know about it being
overturned you know it likely happens i
think i think it's a war on women to be
honest i mean i and i think it affects
everybody okay not just women also um i
mean
you know if man's out cheating he
doesn't want his mistress getting
pregnant she gets pregnant
what can you do
that's kind of letting a piece of guy
off the hook though isn't it i mean yeah
yeah but me too yeah i shouldn't be
cheating yeah um what is i
what is it that you said war on women
what is it that you think will happen
with to women specifically if roe v wade
is you know overturned let's act as
though it's going to be overturned i
know it's a leak but yeah um i just
think it just takes away that choice and
it just it just sucks
but let me ask why do you think it takes
away that choice like what do you think
happens when roe v wade gets overturned
i think this is something that a lot of
people maybe are a little confused about
well it gives the states the choice to
um
give the states the
choice to
choose what they want to do but i think
i i mean i may be wrong but i think some
states have already
banned plan b something like that there
was a rumor about i think it was
tennessee or minnesota mississippi yes
something like that okay it just means
you have to get it from a doctor and not
just get it like pick it up and say oh
no just pick it up
i mean i guess that makes sense but yeah
i mean it just sucks i don't really have
much more than that i just think
but do you think that the states should
have the right to be able to determine
abortion laws um cause you'll still it
won't change the laws and like yeah
that's all robbie weighed over turning
means that colorado you know can have
abortion like they have all the way up
until nine months yeah and texas can
have a heartbeat bill
yeah
i mean
we don't know yet i guess we'll see what
happens
well that is what's going to happen
right now it's not there won't be a
federal ban on abortion
so it's just it'll happen on a state
level where states can place
restrictions which they weren't allowed
to before yeah and now it allows the
states to place restrictions yeah
and that's based on like people voting
for that in each state right
yeah they're representatives yeah i mean
the overturning of roe v wade is the
supreme court justices obviously so
that's not a a voting issue you're going
to really vote them they have lifetime
appointments but it's it's after that
yeah the people of texas want to have a
limitation more of oklahoma they can do
it and if the people of colorado or
virginia or california don't want to
they don't have to rather than like
federally yeah federally what happened
between with roe v wade was basically uh
particularly in the first trimester
states were not allowed to place
restrictions
and so recently you know there was a
bill that there was a case that went up
and challenged it but they said well we
should have the right to in this state
place restrictions
uh in our state and they said yeah
roe v wade is kind of bad law because
you know there's no constitutional right
to an abortion
um so it should be determined by the
states yeah
i mean i guess i mean everybody has a
different opinion so you know that's all
but we're gonna go get so much
dude
sure yeah
sarah sarah all right okay
all right so darien we're just talking
with people now you know there were
these big protests here a few days ago
okay so we didn't really want to get
into that parade you don't end up having
very productive conversations um have
you you've heard about the leak robbie
wade being overturned he stephen just
told me about it actually okay you know
i haven't been keeping up but uh he was
telling me about you know how some
people are taking it as if uh they're
just abolishing abortion
that's how that's what a lot of the
protests were yeah right
but from what it is was saying that
that's not the case right so i'd like to
get them more get to know a little bit
more information about that but okay so
uh well we kind of have two separate
issues i guess sort of and it doesn't
really matter we've addressed this i
don't know if you're pro-life or
pro-choice
it depends it depends on how far along
the pregnancy is okay
that relates exactly to roe v wade so
roe v wade basically was a case
where they specifically barred states
from setting any kind of limitations on
abortion in the first trimester and so
some laws like the texas heartbeat law
there were the case in mississippi that
went up to the supreme court the supreme
court just ruled that you know what
states can determine their own abortion
laws okay so with roe v wade being
overturned it does mean that some states
can outright ban abortion if they want
or they can place limitations like you
know heartbeat which is well within the
first trimester and then a place like
colorado or virginia or new jersey
they can have their late-term abortion
laws which they have they allow
abortions well into the third trimester
it just makes it uh
a scenario where it goes back to the
states they can determine their own laws
regarding abortion limitations right
okay so that's the fallout from it
what do you think about that
i think states should have their own i
think they should have their own
depending on where you are um but i
don't see a problem also with everyone
being under one ideology as well
um
you said depending on how far along the
child is i would say it's almost murder
if the child is you know alive and it's
not just a fetus right you know but
um you know
earlier along in the pregnancy i'm
definitely pro-choice in regards to that
okay um when when would you determine
kind of
what say after the first try yesterday
after the first trimester
after 12 weeks
okay what about you know the fact for
example that like there is a heartbeat
before that that there's a separate
heartbeat so that's the basis for some
of these laws that if there's a separate
heartbeat that you can't abort or you
know the thing that for example the toes
are developed or certain organs so it
just i wonder what changes for example
from week 11 to week 12 right and this
is a conversation that everyone has and
for me i don't know like if
you know when the baby i i would say
this because like you said i don't know
exactly when the heartbeat you know
starts but i would say if
you know if the heartbeat is if it's a
lie
you know i would say i would i would say
adoption would be
you know a better a better choice as
opposed to you know taking a life well
you get the heartbeat like at six weeks
and then you get a more developed heart
it's like they say it's a tube but the
heart develops and about well i don't
are you a dad or all do you have
anything oh yeah
yeah okay so did you ever do the
ultrasound where you see the heartbeat
oh yeah yeah so that's well before the
end of the first trimester you're
actually right about that yeah and did
you feel like that was alive when you
saw that yeah exactly i do
yeah i mean like for me it was crazy
like oh my gosh i better not i don't
know about you but i had twins i was
just paranoid where i was like all right
i just gotta make sure you don't fall
down the stairs
because there's nothing much you can do
exactly it's the life you need to
protect you know exactly so i'm all for
that so that's why i say first trimester
only because of my lacking of knowledge
of
when the heartbeat actually starts okay
so then you would in other words before
roe v wade being overturned
a heartbeat bill would not be allowed
because that's in the first trimester
but now with roby weight overturned
states can set a heartbeat bill so you
would say okay they should have the
right to do that
estate
uh i would say i'm not not after the
harvey no well that's what i'm saying a
state candidate
so then yeah so it's
pretty reasonable then it seems like you
know you're kind of like most americans
where most americans consider themselves
pro-choice until a certain point right
it gets a little bit difficult when you
ask americans to define where that point
is
i'm kind of like we just experienced now
but i do think that it's you know being
a little mis represented if you've seen
the protests and i'm sure you probably
might have been under the impression at
one point that overturning roe v wade
was a ban on abortion right yeah that's
not the case it just goes back to the
states do you think that at the very
least
that's a reasonable decision for them
that is a reasonable decision yeah okay
that's about it yeah and
i think you agree with most americans
and i think if you uh if you take the
time to do like a little more research
on it don't take my word for it
i promise you i'm not lying but i
encourage you to assume that i am lying
you know make sure you talk with other
people about it because the more people
know what roe v wade is
and then it goes to the states
then we'll have less division in this
country as opposed to yelling about
banning abortion and it not being you
know my body my choice all the way up
until
nine months i mean let me ask you this
because the most radical abortion bills
that they would consider
on those on the left would be things
like the heartbeat pill that exists
right now
um or like the mississippi law
but in states like colorado or places
like virginia
they can abort all the way up to nine
months oh wow
what do you think is
let's say we take the extreme abortion
all the way up until nine months or a
complete ban
what would you be more comfortable with
because one is already happening
abortion up till nine months it's
happening right now the band doesn't
exist
like i'm pro-life so i would say a
complete band over all the way up to
nine months if we're going if i have to
choose an extreme yeah you would choose
i would choose yeah which is the band i
think that's that's not a poll that's
out there i think probably a lot of
americans would feel that way we're not
there that's not what we have to decide
right right but the truth is a lot of
people don't know that right now this
happens in many states right i mean
there are some states i don't know if
you're aware of uh
it was elizabeth warren klobuchar a few
democrats voted against the infants born
alive act and what was happening uh in
places like i believe illinois virginia
i don't know the exact states babies
that survived abortions were being left
to die
and the bill just demanded that babies
that survived abortions just be given be
legally required the same uh medical
attention that all babies are given
as opposed to just because you don't
want them but they already survived the
abortion that come out of the birth
canal and there were a lot of democrats
who voted against that really because
they thought that was infringing on
abortion rights
that's not right man
not right they do deserve the same
treatment now i will like are there any
birth defects that go along with
survival not necessarily no it's just if
a baby survived an abortion that you
know they attempted to abort and the
baby survived it um
there were instances where they weren't
being given medical that's not right
yeah there's actually you can watch an
interview with the governor of virginia
saying that what would happen in that
instance is we would make keep the baby
comfortable and then have a discussion
with the mother as to what she wants to
do right meaning
you could still let that baby die and
that's happening today
so i in my opinion
that's more extreme
than the overturning of roe v wade which
just gives it back to the states
because they'll still be able to do that
in virginia as sick as it is to me but
they'll still be able to do it yeah that
is safe yeah isn't it yeah it turns your
stomach yeah it is
actually as a father
how old are your uh your little ones i
have uh 10 12
10 12 and 4. okay so they're spaced out
there so i'm gonna say you're not
looking you're not looking to an empty
nest for a while with that four-year-old
one of them will be telling you he hates
you or she hates you while the other one
still thinks you're the best you know so
balance your self-esteem yeah
oh thank you darren i appreciate it
[Music]
hello hey all right you got five minutes
to talk
great what's your name casey casey all
right okay well that ties in perfectly
because we're talking about the you know
all these protests there a couple days
ago hear about the roe v wade situation
sure absolutely i've been following that
yes okay so
first let me ask you you can see
yourself
pro-choice or like pro-choice with
limitations how would you define um i'm
definitely pro-choice okay you know um
i'm definitely pro-choice okay
what's your opinion on the
it's a leak right now obviously sure but
if it's true
the overturning of roe v wade
um it's ridiculous you know as a woman i
think it's
astronomical how we could consider and
no offense to you
but how a heterosexual male can tell me
what i should and should not do with my
body okay and what that actually means
um i think there's so many stipulations
that go into this you know there's a lot
of circumstances and just you know i was
told i couldn't have children um i'm
sorry it's okay but so this topic is
like super sensitive to me and of course
in my family um but i know
because you wouldn't need to have an
abortion i wouldn't need to have one um
but let's just say the opportunity ever
arose itself um there's all kind of
medical conditions and reasons topical
pregnancies uh tubal pregnancies things
that have happened to your body um that
require abortions for medical reasons
for us as women to like literally live
and survive um so for you to say i'm
you're forcing me to either go through
that experience and or heaven forbid you
know my kid is you know there's all kind
of testing that goes on early in your
pregnancy sure um and they'll let you
know that there's fluid on the brain for
a baby or something like that and they
do not recommend
you um continuing off that pregnancy i'm
also 31
and so a lot of us are getting pregnant
later in life
so sometimes that's an issue right and
it could be a health risk for the mother
and the baby so whatever your reasoning
is more importantly you could just be 18
and decide that that's not the decision
that you want to make today and you're
not comfortable with that you could be a
victim of rape i don't care what your
reasoning is i think it's a hundred
percent your choice to decide so none of
those other things matter then we could
just eliminate all that just do you
think people should get abortion for
whatever reason i think you should be
able to make any decision
as far as hipaa laws are concerned for
yourself and your body at any time so
what is your uh because a lot of people
have different interpretations or
understandings of what the overturning
of roe v wade
is actually means yeah what is your
interpretation of what would happen if
roe v wade my interpretation is that it
doesn't matter what your reasoning is
and you can correct me if i'm wrong that
abortions will now be illegal or
released in the state of texas um for
anybody
no correct me no it's not no it's and
that's it just gives it gives the right
to states to make their own laws
regarding abortion restrictions sure
colorado you know new jersey virginia of
california states that have abortion
laws all the way up until and including
nine months they can still do that so
let me ask you a question do you think
texas is gonna
vote in which direction
well i i don't want to get i'll get into
my opinion in a second um but i want to
sort of
discuss the issue of whether we agree on
the fact that it's good or bad law so
it's not it's not it's not banning
abortion it puts it back to the states i
don't agree with that okay so
what do you think should happen that you
think there should be a federal
uh it should be enshrined in the federal
law that abortion is a
constitutional right i think it took a
long time for roe versus way to even
become about and to pass and that if we
aren't careful history will continue to
repeat itself over and over again so the
fact that that law is what it is i don't
know why we're going back and trying to
now
tweak that doesn't make sense well are
you um and forgive me this is not meant
to be a gotcha at all it's law is
complicated and roby weight is
complicated you know that's why i had
roe v wade then yet planned parenthood
versus casey and these it's always been
a complex
yes exactly uh see we tied us called the
callback but uh roe v wade
the issue was right roe v wade was sort
of uh under the guise it was it was
settled into the guys of the 14th
amendment the due process cost okay
so there's no constitutional right to an
abortion and essentially because you
just mentioned sort of the hipaa laws
and the idea was that under the due
process clause there's a right to
privacy which also isn't necessarily a
constitutional right but under the due
process clause that a woman uh had that
right to privacy with her doctor
and allowed states to set limitations
only after the first trimester so it
banned state setting limitations
within the first trimester absolutely
okay and then you have states that for
example have like a heartbeat bill
things that occur before the second
trimester
that kind of kicked it up to the supreme
court and they looked at it and this is
something that even ruth bader ginsburg
said but they said you know what this is
this is just sort of bad law so it has
to go back to the states okay
so that was the basis for roe v wade um
does that change your opinion at all
that there really is there's no
constitutional right to an abortion
not necessarily because when we when we
talk about first trimester i think i
also don't agree that after your first
trimester you should be looking at
options as far as abortion right because
at this point your fetus is a full-grown
fetus you know there's things that are
happening your baby's developing so i i
understand
up until that point okay but on a
state-to-state basis or a federal basis
to me i guess in that first trimester
it's still up to me and my doctor so so
it sounds like you're saying you do
support eliminating abortion as an
option after the first trimester i do i
agree with that okay um
what changes for example from week 11 to
week 12 that makes it no longer
acceptable eyeballs fingers toes hair i
mean you know you're going from this
small cell i mean just but that happens
before the second trimester well but the
thing is
why is plan b a thing right there's a
reason why day after something you can
go into cvs right now and a young lady
can say i know i
did whatever i did last night and i'm
going to make sure everyone protected
myself so i did what i did i'm assuming
sex sure yeah and so to me
you saying okay here at this point in
time there's people who are i'm not a
doctor right obviously uh i wouldn't be
wearing this
neither am i i don't know if you can
tell so you know somebody somewhere sat
down and said this makes sense who gets
paid a lot more money than me and
understands the anatomy of the human
body but yeah i know that's kind of the
issue though right is because no one has
sit down and said it made sense
for example in a place like colorado you
can have an abortion
all the way up until eight nine months
yeah no i don't agree with that okay and
that'll still be the law in colorado
and in virginia you know you had the
governor where there were babies who
survived abortions and they were still
being allowed to die because technically
they tried to abort them they'll still
be allowed to do that in virginia well
what's the difference between that and
some girl throwing herself down the
stairs people are going to do what they
want to do when they want to do it well
no this is about babies who were born
who survived abortions and they were
just leaving it in a room to die sure
but you're saying in colorado at eight
months it's still legal for them to get
abortions which i didn't know that's
what you're saying yes okay so if a
lady's eight months pregnant and she's
just in dire whatever mental state and
she decides she doesn't want to have
that kid what does this stop her from
jumping off the top of this building and
or pushing herself down the stairs well
i don't know hopefully there'd be some
bars on the window we don't know we
don't know right but i'm just i'm just
trying to understand your position
because this is something that's
obviously a heated issue and i'm trying
to see where there is common ground it
sounded to me like you were saying after
the second trimester no abortion but now
it sounds like you're saying yeah it
should be fine for a place like colorado
to have abortions at 78. no i'm not
saying that at all i literally said i do
not agree with that so you still think
but what i don't think is that we should
go so far back that we're saying every
state should make their own opinion
before the first trimester after the
second trimester because to me i live in
texas i'm originally from california and
i know we vote very differently yes
between
i hope that you're not one of those who
comes from california brings your
politics here because he left for a
reason right i didn't leave my choice my
parents probably here oh so i i think
views are going to very much differ in
living in the bible belt i've seen yeah
you know how that can affect people um
i've seen how it affects me as a black
person a hundred and twelve percent so
uh 12. what's the 12 percent yeah what's
the 12 past 100. i literally went to a
restaurant when i was eight years old
and they told my cheerleading coach that
i couldn't go into their restaurant
because i was black and that was in
texas and it would never happen that's
terrible
so there's just things that definitely
happened in california
okay
i appreciate talking about california
this is really fun okay
you're saying no racists in california
come on there's no way ever been to
venice
i've seen some i live in california too
i definitely see that i've seen racists
everywhere
yeah yeah definitely some
neo-nazis in california
thank you
wasn't there a movie like american
history x or something was it
was it
was that longview texas
i don't know
maybe tyler
it's a really nasty way
have you been following us the roe v
wade
situation all right can i ask you about
it because we're strong with people have
cause you know there were these protests
here all across
this lawn a couple days ago and that's
what we didn't ask people there because
it was pretty heated you know and you
don't really end up having good
conversations i'm stephen by the way hi
i'm tammy tammy yes i just follow the y
or i y okay
so tammy you said that you're pro you're
kind of you're pro-choice yeah so okay
have you been following the you haven't
been following the rovi wade situation
yes i have okay so what is your opinion
on it's a leak but a ledge but it seems
like it's very likely the court will
overturn
roe v wade what's your opinion on that
as
i mean from your perspective as someone
who's pro-choice from what i understand
but
specifically on this kind of piece of
law um
i hope they don't um
revoke the entire roe versus wade
legislation okay i just hope that
they make whatever current modifications
they need to
for you know
2020 and to the future yeah so i don't
know a lot of people are because it gets
confusing right with some of the supreme
court law and precedent um
what happens with roe v wade a lot of
people think that means there's a ban on
abortion it doesn't
what it means if it gets overturned is
it goes back to states so the states can
place restrictions or a state can ban
abortion if they want uh and then states
like colorado like new jersey like
california that have abortions you know
all the way up until nine months can
still do that but it's on a
state-by-state basis
uh what do you what do you think about
that considering that that's what would
what would happen
um
i hope the local um
you know state legislation they will
weigh both sides the pro-choice and the
pro-life yeah and um when i vote i'll
vote pro-choice okay you vote pro-choice
but do you think it's
it's at least a reasonable decision to
say states should have the right to
decide yes uh-huh yeah okay so you're
not against the overturning of it but
you would like in your state for there
to be access to abortion yes uh-huh okay
that seems to be a lot of people uh most
people but the media sort of framed it
as though it's an outright ban on
abortion right which scares people and
it's not really what happens well let me
ask you this uh your pro-choice if you
were to vote in your state
should there be any limitations on
abortion at all where where do we draw
that line let's say in texas what would
you like to see if you could wave your
magic wand and have you know any type of
laws
um well what i would like to see is the
the medical community work with the
families
and help them to make those decisions
you know it's a private health decision
and so i hope that um
they will seek counsel from their
medical providers
do you think do you believe that there's
a cut off as far as abortion you know
where it should no longer be
allowed yes uh-huh yes i think the
doctors can help
well when do you think that should be
though for example so it sounds like
you're not supporting for example states
that have abortion up until and
including nine months
does that seem yeah that seems too far
yeah that's too far um unless um
like i said um it's case-by-case medical
case by case
and unless something is wrong with the
fetus and the doctor
has already determined that there
something has to happen yeah
which is very rare obviously and they
usually catch that well before nine
months there's no medical reason for a
nine month abortion or eight month or
seven months so if you're living in
texas where would you like to see that
line drawn you know because different
states will be able to establish a
different laws would you like it to be
you know no abortions after the first
trimester second trimester heartbeat
where should the line be drawn for
general abortions
um again i say just
i think you should seek help with your
medical provider
and let your
ob gyn
specialist assist you with making those
decisions okay yeah so so no limitations
at the state level
yes that's correct okay yeah all right
uh in texas
into texas all right well there you go i
appreciate it thank you very much for
taking the time
so all right what's your name i'm bella
nice to meet you nice to meet you bella
that's a pretty name until thorn had to
ruin it for everything yeah i know right
oh my gosh
so uh bella are you uh are you familiar
with even following the roby way
okay
so let me ask you the first question
what do you think about the fact that
it was leaked
well i think that
in itself is very scary because the
privacy leak yeah you know and i just
don't understand how something like that
could have happened right
it is pretty scary and unprecedented i
mean
yeah the court is sort of must be immune
from that yeah okay so what's your
opinion on the assuming that it's all
correct and it's been mostly confirmed
the overturning of roe v wade i just
i mean
to answer your question just very simply
i just don't understand the whole debate
whereas like like women should just be
able to govern their own bodies okay you
know well that's a different
conversation right it's like where life
begins and if it's your body or not
before we get to that we can talk about
that if you'd like to
but i i'd like to sort of talk because a
lot of people
don't really know what overturning roe v
wade means yeah and that's by design
from the media they've obfuscated made
it complicated
what is your impression of what happens
if roe v wade is overturned
well from what i've understood isn't it
correct that um
the whole thing is about
like the document was leaked and i had a
decision
regarding
how women's bodies should be
governed no so basically just you know
roe v wade i don't know if let's go back
to kind of roe v wade when it happened
roe v wade there's no constitutional
rights to an abortion right it was
oh yeah that's sort of predicated on the
14th amendment the due process clause
which they interpreted as a right to
privacy and so women with their doctor
and all roe v wade really
what it did was it said that states
could not place any restrictions
uh on pregnancies or on abortions right
in the first trimester
all that happens is if it gets gets
overturned is that changes where it goes
on a state-by-state basis so california
can make their own law yeah texas can
make their own law
so if you want to have abortion all the
way up until third trimester eight
months like some states nine months like
some states they can do it in a place
like texas would legally be allowed to
have like a heartbeat though right
yeah i think i think it is difficult
to determine
all of that but at the same time i mean
i just think that but going back to the
states like i think it's i think it's
odd if we have
if we're leaving the choice up to states
to make that decision that makes sense
like i feel like
holistically it should just be
legal okay well what it's just saying is
it's not
illegal federally right right and states
can place restrictions that they want
right so i mean there are a lot of
things right that we let states do
property taxes i mean the way you do
your education for example just public
schools some states have more agreements
with charter schools so this is just
another example of going to states
rights is that
i guess the question is concerning you
know there were protests here and across
the country that have gotten violent and
outside of supreme court justice's
houses which i think we agree on the
leak is a bad thing the doxing is a bad
thing yeah yeah really do we really
think that the
the end result of overturning it is that
extreme that it warrants that kind of a
reaction it's not a ban on abortion
yeah
it's not a ban on abortion i just
i mean
i'm sorry if i sound redundant but no no
i think the whole
the whole premise i think the whole
thing
is is just silly
when we're like
talking about
what women can and can't do with
their bodies and their choices
yeah well then that gets to the idea
it's not really agreed upon yeah right
now
if you want to get to that conversation
we can have that conversation i'll tell
you i am i am pro-life
um just so you know i think that roe v
wade is bad law uh and there are a lot
of even ruth bader ginsburg said that
really wasn't a good ruling because it's
not a there's no constitutional right to
an abortion she said she thought that at
some point it would probably be undone
so that's a separate issue people
protesting sort of the changing of the
law
on the issue of you know what women do
with their own bodies and this is why it
goes to states
can you at least understand
because i can understand why you would
say that
i can understand the argument
um can you understand why someone else
in particularly states
and their legislators might say okay
but when there's another heartbeat it's
not your own body when there's another
pair of eyes fingers toes it's not your
own body and they have
the right as they do in other state
issues to determine what limitations are
can you understand why people think it's
not it's very different from any other
issue and that they don't believe it's
your body when there's another i
understand that perspective
because
at that point when you start to have a
heartbeat at a certain period of time
it does become another person involved
okay because developmentally right
but
i i think i think i do agree with the
fact that there should be at least some
kind of cut off point
but
the whole thing with like
when do you think that cut off should be
i mean
i feel like if there isn't a cutoff then
at that point
it's just kind of like well you had a
long time to decide whether or not this
was right gonna be the choice for you
right
so
i can't give you an exact number but i
feel like at least before the fetus is
fully
or at least partially fully formed
yeah i feel like that would be a
reasonable one that'd be reasonable yeah
okay which
is what most states will be doing yeah
um you know can i ask you and this is
just hey uh lane can i grab this from
you just because this is also i think
this might help with americans because a
lot of people so let me kind of give you
an example right in colorado
for example in virginia they can do
abortions all the way up to here yeah
texas says not after
here right a heartbeat bill
about this area where do you think
the cutoff should be
well
and this shows you kind of where things
have developed and what what has
developed
i mean it is a good question
but
it's hard to say i mean it definitely
shouldn't be
anywhere over here
okay but
i mean i would say at least like over
here probably okay i would imagine so
that still includes the first trimester
yeah which roe v wade said
you couldn't place restrictions right
there at week 11 and 12.
yeah and that's how that's what was sort
of brought that's not sort of that's
what was brought to the supreme court
because there were regulations that were
created in this range
and it was technically illegal for the
states to do that well it's just it's
hard to say it
it's
it's an odd
perspective but
i i just think that women should just be
able to decide for themselves but should
they be able to decide for themselves
here and this is the thing because the
question is roby wade i think is bad law
but if someone is going to say it's good
law then it is incumbent upon them to
say when right when when is okay and
when's not and it seems like you believe
there should be some limitations well
think about it this way think about
women who do make the choice to have an
abortion they're already
depending on
their perspective but they're already
gonna be dealing with
psychological repercussions from the
abortion yeah that's very common yeah
there's a lot of trauma i feel like
regardless at what state of development
the baby is in
i mean it's it's what it's a choice that
they have to make
so even at
these weeks
yeah
so you would so you support laws that
allow abortion up until all the way nine
months i would say
i'm just a little confused but you said
depending on where they are
developmentally like those babies are
they're
they can be born right there are plenty
of babies i mean my twins were born
before i know i i probably contradicted
myself
but um
and this doesn't that's why i show it
it's the opposite of a gotcha i'm trying
to understand your perspective
because i will say you know to me the
only way to consistently draw the line
is that fertilization once there's new
dna right uh that's separate from the
mother and the father it's a new
genetic code that determines everything
from you know
hand size eye color male pattern
baldness um
versus
something arbitrary right because i
think then you get into the territory of
up until nine months
and uh
i mean we're no longer a discussion of
viability right if you support that
then that just means it doesn't matter
if the baby is viable or not i have to
run okay because this is the end of my
lunchbox
but
i will just leave you with the fact that
i think this is definitely an
interesting discussion and i think it's
really good to explore it and i do see
your sign i see your viewpoint thank you
and i think that
i think i would have to take a little
bit more time myself to really think
about
exactly i think that's very reasonable
everything
i think we all should yeah as opposed to
yelling at each other you bring up good
points but at the same time i mean
there's just a lot of i understand i
understand where you're coming from i
understand that a lot a lot of people
feel that way would you would we before
you leave we at least agree that the
overturning of roe v wade has been a
little misrepresented in that a lot most
people think it's a ban on abortion
there is the possibility it could be
clouded i mean also when you're dealing
with mass social media right it's very
easy for things to be misinterpreted or
even mainstream media like abc and cnn
and then you're gonna get into the whole
snowden thing like everything's like
like everything's nothing is real yeah
or like big brother's watching 1984. big
brother's definitely watching i think we
both agree that big brother is
definitely watching at this point i mean
at this point i could have somebody a
department of misinformation in a
federal government in my phone like
somebody could be watching me do you
know how you fix that
sticky note
i'm high tech with that yeah thank you
so much all right thank you i really
appreciate it thank you for taking the
time
be well
[Music]
i know you got the jimmy john so you did
it crazy fast
i said it was crowded well i was going
to ask you guys about the roe v wade
situation going on what about you you
have three minutes it's it's more
important to get a female perspective
get out here get out of here yeah i
screwed me right what's your opinion on
the the potential overturning of rovi
with this isn't gonna be is this
recording it could yeah it's recording
but we're trying to get opinions from
people that's all just what your opinion
is on the overturning of ruby wood
okay so you support the roe v wade as it
was before
oh yes yes
you know that was
created as a law by five white guys yes
oh i know
so i'm just saying they decided what
women could do with their bodies yeah
but
so either way that's kind of how it's
going right like sweating right now i
really can't be on i feel like this
might be like
a violation of like
me speaking they don't let you speak
you're not allowed to speak your mind
it's not white men who run that company
is it they shouldn't be able to tell you
what you do with your mouth
go talk to them i want to go with you in
the office no no i'll go to the office
i'll talk to those white guys they can't
tell you what you can't do with your
body i gotta go though uh i got a
meeting to get to okay all right let's
go have your meeting can you just like
not air this i don't know let's just
make sure there are no white guys now
well yeah i just are there white guys in
that meeting you shouldn't be meeting
with them you should be telling them to
meet with you yeah fair enough okay good
yeah it's like it's a black woman
or intersectional who said don't don't
let them be like hey you got to be here
at 11 15.
my point is do your own you know you do
you
hey
what's his name gordo gordo
mary gordo like mortal kombat yeah yeah
yeah
awesome is that why you were named gordo
no it's named after a canadian singer
and uh like gordon lightfoot uh gord
downing fort downey
yeah okay oh i'm canadian so are you
canadian no i'm texting all right
spoilers okay now they're appropriating
canadian culture so uh gordo and mary
thanks for taking the time you know
they're just a great conversation with
those folks so friendly um have you been
following kind of the roe v wade yeah
we're very very close okay uh what's
your opinion on that um i think it's
pretty [ __ ] up what's going on um i
don't like i think everybody should have
the right to
choose well particularly women i think
when it's something that's affecting
your body you should have the right to
choose how your um
how you you should have the right to
choose how you go about your own health
uh and i think taking that away from
people and not even just taking away but
criminalizing it is a very backwards
step for a country that prides itself on
freedom
criminalizing abortion yeah okay and uh
what do you think right what's your
opinion i think it's terrible it's awful
same same reasoning yeah so um let me
ask you this is is it your impression
that roby wade
overturning well let me ask you this
first what do you think about the leak
and the fact that this was leaked from
the supreme court uh i think it's pretty
crazy to have like a leak of that
magnitude i think it's also very
important that uh
um
that we have this knowledge so you can
at least like talk about it before this
all happens we have a very uh hard right
weaning uh leaning a supreme court right
now um which we've had of course this is
america says we've had a
whether democrat or republican uh in the
very large gist of the political scale
uh we're right leaning throughout our
history um
and but right now it's to an extent that
we really haven't seen in a very very
long time really since the civil war um
so
i think it's
when you start taking away rights that
have been affirmed over and over and
over um
on this magnitude i think it's important
i'm sorry i'm giving you i thought but
you sound you sound like you're pretty
right-wing because you talked about
freedoms and personal liberties that's
uh no i think freedom and personal
liberties right-wing or left-wing
there's always uh bipartisan issues and
no matter who you are you're [ __ ]
communist you want your communists
because you think freedom is of this way
and i'm not a communist but uh and
you're hard right-wing it's because you
want freedoms in this way everybody has
their own ideas of how to get there no
communism is not about freedom it's
pretty clearly expressive it's it's
anti-freedom like there's no one who
argues that communism is freedom there
are there's communists that argue that
um
not marx or
lenin marx does argue about the freedom
that comes with communism it's about the
leadership of the proletariat which is
uh uh the individual which if you're
into individualism i'd assume
is it is it freedom if you're taking my
rights away so well this is basically my
own body sure this is something i say
there's kind of two different questions
you know the idea and if we want to talk
about sort of abortion we can i i sort
of want to discuss the the impression of
the law so you mentioned like federally
you know criminalizing abortion are you
under the impression that that's what
the overturning of roe v wade knows the
overturning of roe v wade is giving
states the right to uh criminalize
abortion it's okay states to set their
own rules but if you go deeper into it
more specifically like in the second
first trimester
if you get into this uh there is a
big discrepancy particularly in the us
between uh income levels and if you
particularly in a state like texas which
is [ __ ] huge as you know yeah um
if you don't make enough like it costs
to get to another state to have an
abortion just to travel out it's going
to be like gas prices are incredibly
high all this yeah um
what do they get to another or are they
over like four or four or something yeah
it's not that bad that's pretty he just
said it was bad uh it seems like you're
couching it a little bit anyways anyway
but yeah like california if you don't
have the money which a lot of there are
quite a lot of low-income people not
just in texas but in the us in general
to get out to access your right to an
abortion which isn't even your right
unless you're in another state um
you can only do that if you have money
so unless there's
um i'm against criminalizing abortion
completely but if you want to go like
that and you still care about personal
freedoms and rights there should be like
very hardcore programs to allow the
people that do want it to go to another
state and how it's set up right now it's
gonna
it's leading the way to make it not just
illegal to have an abortion within texas
or whatever state that criminalizes it
but to make it criminal to go to another
state uh
that to get an abortion and i think
that's like pretty it's pretty
totalitarian an authoritarian
your impression that it makes it would
make it criminal to go to another state
to get an abortion no but that's what
it's leading up to because these are
precedents we're talking about
this is how the supreme court i haven't
heard anything i haven't heard that
suggested that
i just told you this is how precedents
work in legal in legal
uh scenarios you're setting a very large
president like this which uh gives
people the right to go further and
further and further the whole roe v wade
precedent is based on that it's not
allowed this uh abortion wasn't
mentioned in the constitution but also
the right to marry uh interracially
isn't in the constitution um the right
to like uh all a lot of things that we
take as very granted and that are
important aren't mentioned in the
constitution so i think uh this is like
a very dangerous thing that's happening
right now yeah i think
there's and your question was now i
understand where you're coming from i
would disagree with first off do you
mean precedent or precedence used both
precedent okay precedent yeah um and
you were out you asked me a question
earlier
i asked you a question yeah you asked me
a question i wanted to get to the
supreme court kind of roby wade law so i
actually appreciate that you understand
that it goes to the states and the
states have that you know have that
right because you actually understand
what roe v wade over being overturned is
a lot of people think that there's a
federal criminalizing of abortion which
isn't really the case no it's it's legal
it's allowed it to the states yeah i
don't really i haven't seen any uh
literature that suggests
already have a uh
and it's also i think it's also very
difficult to when it leads it to the
states because the gerrymandering is so
intense in places like texas and stuff
which really skews the political outlook
when uh the large majority of people in
cities like this like dallas uh do vote
uh blue and i'm not a democrat in fact
i'm very heavily against the democratic
party just about as equally as much as
i'm against the republican party i think
the us politics are [ __ ] across the
board
so how would you identify um i am
progressive left-wing i believe uh in
human rights which i mean i think we all
deserve a right to
we're the richest country in the world
and it's 2022 we're very progressive uh
we have the right to health care we have
the right to bodily autonomy and to be
an individual person to
uh chase your self-actualization be the
person you want to be as long as you're
not harming anybody else i know this is
where it comes down to because in
abortion uh in this rhetoric it always
comes down to whether you believe
a fetus is a person or not and i believe
because i don't remember and nobody
remembers what they were as a fetus
because you're not sentient i don't
believe uh you're a person until you're
born so you're a sentient being i don't
remember anything before my second
birthday
yeah me neither which is what um
well i'm also not advocating for
aborting someone at a year old but
of sentience right yeah right to your
own body but you're not even you're not
in the world why are you forcing women
to carry out a pregnancy that they can't
afford that you know that would lead up
to a lot of
high rates of infant mortality people
can't take care of a child people can't
go to the doctor
it's
it's a problem people the health care
system is awful it you can't afford
to have a child in this country it's
expensive right i'm 21. i could never
afford to have a child
i
can't i can
afford my health insurance that
is expensive but once a year
twice a year and go to the doctor but
that's about it that i can't afford to
go to a hospital and have a child we
can't even afford to go to the hospital
i can't afford housing in this state in
this country yeah i can't even afford i
can't even afford to go to the doctor in
general if i get actually sick sick like
i'm
people that make a hundred thousand
dollars a year you get cancer you're
bankrupt where do you work
uh right now i just got back from europe
uh doing a study abroad so this is my
first day back so i don't have a
journalist
i study human rights actually okay cool
what are human rights and international
studies where were we studying barcelona
at like a university yeah in iau is the
university it's my final semester so i
was just finishing i've already finished
my degree i was just doing like my
electives basically and traveling
um yeah i studied human rights at smu
actually okay so um and you said you
can't afford a house
who can afford a house like i'm 23 who
can afford a house at 23 unless you're
at mark or you said you can't afford a
place to live uh so we're well i could i
could afford a place to live if i was
willing
compared to five years ago it was very
easy for me if for five years ago i
could go bartend like which is what i
normally do um and i can afford a decent
place for like 800 700 a month in dallas
it's very hard to find like to get a
place that's not cockroach infested and
like falling down i have to have like
two or three roommates which is normal
um
but i mean i've been here my entire life
and it's just getting uh i've seen the
change firsthand hand
we bought our house for eighty thousand
dollars uh that neighborhood's about
four hundred thousand dollars now
because of these multi-corporations
coming out like vanguard and blackrock
yeah yeah yeah we'd probably agree you
know elizabeth warren said they should
be too big to fail i don't think any
company is too big to fail they should
fail um yeah i think
yeah but i understand where you're going
with this uh situation and i also
believe that i well i believe that uh
when a corporation gets uh pass a
certain threshold of money they should
be checked and limited by the government
because um i believe it was thomas
jefferson jefferson has a quote where he
talks about if uh the power goes towards
if the power goes
is directed towards the banks i wish i
could you can look it up later if you
want you probably won't because i know
you like to nitpick your things nothing
against you no this would be totally
unedited but you can uh i really
appreciate everything you've been saying
there's a thing about thomas jefferson
that talks about um
[Music]
uh
when the money is like goes you can look
up thomas jefferson bank quote i believe
and when basically when the banks if
they're given too much money and by
banks it's uh capital capital interest
uh goes above the people it's no longer
a democracy and it's true uh this is my
shirt i certainly agree so we really
pride ourselves on being a democracy but
we're not i think we can find common
ground there he's in the sense that i
find common ground with a lot of
right-wing people but yeah uh our ideals
are against each other because they're
certain
can you let me speak
i think we're saying the same thing on
too big to fail i think that big banks
want to privatize profits and socialize
losses right and i think you're saying
pick a lane so where we won't find
common ground is more so socialize the
banks i'm saying about socialized losses
can you expand on that well they get
bailed out by the taxpayers
in other words when the bank has a
problem it's they're insured by the
federal government yeah yeah and so
that's the taxpayer and that's people
who really shouldn't even people who are
middle class people or middle class
even past them we agree on that i do
agree on that
but even past that what what the hell do
we get as taxpayers even without that
we're one of the richest nations in the
world we don't have our free health care
we don't have a public transport system
that's adequate dallas we have a public
transport system but come on it's
[ __ ] wellington
the us there's like compared to europe
like europe you don't need a car uh
really you can survive quite easily
without one uh for most of the us if you
don't have a car you are struggling you
don't have a life you don't you don't
have the ability to have a social life
it's difficult to get to work um the us
is quite big
we don't invest at all in
we don't invest in
the social good really with any uh of
our tax money our tax money is uh
it goes to i don't really know that i i
agree with that i mean you're doing many
many trillions of dollars spent in the
war on poverty and just we just talked
about multiple joining
dallas right now and you see the
homeless people in every corner no i
agree i just don't think that the
federal spending on the war in poverty
works just like the war on drugs hasn't
worked oh yeah i don't think throwing
more money at it
so then what are you going for well i
think the problem there right is we both
agree there's corruption there's a lot
of money that's being spent it's not
being spent the right way i don't
necessarily think that all those things
are fundamental human rights but i
certainly would argue that the money is
being spent very poorly i mean there's a
lot of money being spent we have a
spending problem and it's not going
anywhere useful but i wanted to get back
to kind of roe v wade uh and the subject
let me ask you this because there are
people for example those we had four uh
four people there you know
african-americans who
had it i don't know this is
african-american i said four oh four
they support ooh careful with your
presumptions no i i misheard you it
wasn't a presumption it found it
the foreign four that you said before
okay
i didn't
what were you asking
is um you know they so that their point
of view was okay they were pro-choice
um and then she was a mother of four and
when i asked her about the texas
heartbeat bill she said well yeah of
course after a heartbeat because she did
an ultrasound she said that's a life
that's a separate heart whose heart are
you stopping my question to you is this
because i know you're coming in hot and
and i'm not appreciative i'm really
speaking like uh i'm not coming in hard
i'm not being here can you understand
the other perspective where someone says
someone does certainly have
more than half the country believe it a
limitation at some point that at a
certain point
it's no longer your own body that's
their argument and that's why the
supreme court is said it's bad law and
states should have the right
to enforce those regulations
will the fetus survive
if it's outside of your body
so you don't have any children right no
i don't because a baby won't survive
outside the body no it's relying on your
body right a baby won't survive outside
of the body but i mean a baby
delivered naturally won't survive i mean
we're talking about fetus right now i'm
talking about a fetus so what changes
from let's say
eight weeks and six days
oh sorry eight months four you know
three weeks six days to nine months is
it just inside outside the womb that
makes it a person well one's a fetus and
one's a baby but why is one a fetus if
it's it's not and it's just one day
it's not relying on your body to
your
umbilical cord and once it's outside and
cut so is that what defines person is
the umbilical cord my opinion yeah
so what if a woman gives birth and they
haven't cut the cord yet does that mean
they can abort the baby nobody but
nobody's even talking about aborting
like a baby that's still on the court it
actually does exist it actually doesn't
just there was a there was a bill but we
have like so many billions of people
it was a bill
and i feel like i've been pretty
respectful letting you talk a lot and go
into different directions well you're
interviewing me so of course i would
talk a lot so yeah and i'm also being
respectful i think interrupting is
different from talking a lot would we
agree and yeah interrupted hurry
to leave it's okay um well i would like
to hear her i'm having a conversation
okay so um the umbilical is that what
defines person i mean the point that
other people are defining first and
people define it differently i
understand that for example these four
african-americans said okay heartbeat
they agree with the texas bill some
people think that it's after the first
trimester but at a certain where would
you define when a person when it's a
person why is it called the heartbeat
bill
because that's one you can detect a
fetal heartbeat can you detect a fetal
heartbeat at six weeks yes
i'm not sure about that yeah you can
okay so what is it you used to be able
to but you can now with more advanced
ultras and i just had twins so yeah i
know what is what is your argument
no my my question is can you understand
in other words
those people who were horrified right at
the idea of aborting a baby after a
heartbeat then there are a lot of
americans who believe that okay once it
has its own fingers toes sex you know
there are people who believe like i i
believe in the woman's choice i believe
in
the right to choose so when does that
line i guess when is there the line of
and this is why it's going to stay i
mean i've talked to many people many
people that are pro-choice about this i
know
i mean i believe the woman has the right
to abort a child whenever they want so
all the way up until nine months
including birth
yeah and you don't believe that that
baby is a person at eight months seven
even though they could be born in bible
because you said viability earlier they
are viable
it's viable in 21 weeks if it's a person
i mean if it's still
in your body you have the choice to do
what you want so it's a location what
determines a person in your body or
outside of your body
well once
once it's delivered you
carry okay first of all nobody really
wants to abort a child at eight months
it happens all the time
for many reasons if they i've had a
couple friends with abortions there's
never any one there's always that like
when they find out yes
a year my problem also with this
abortion bill is that it's making it so
they want to abort the child when it
when it's
it does happen
and there are states that restrict it
but there are some states that don't my
question is would you restrict it then
if you're saying no okay so someone
should be able to abort it eight months
nine months um if that's what they
choose okay
why why because it's their body so it's
their choice so
it's a person who is able to have a
child
so it's their choice so if a woman is
eight months pregnant using your premise
since we've gone to this does that woman
have 20 fingers does she have 20 toes
does she have a penis if it's a boy what
is it does she have two brains what does
that matter well because you're ending
the life the functioning life of another
human being that has all of those things
so i'm saying you're saying that's her
body so that woman has 20 toes
what does that matter
it's not her body she doesn't have 20
fingers in total oh you're saying uh 10
fingers plus her 10 fingers that's 20
fingers so is it still the one child
whether you would call it a child or a
fetus i know this is what it comes down
to is it a child or a fetus in my
opinion when it's in your body the
medical idea of what you call it a fetus
is a fetus um
if you aborted me when i was a fetus i'm
not gonna [ __ ] playing cause i don't
know
uh like cleansing or anything like that
i'm talking about you brought up
sentience and i'm just saying that's an
important distinction to make because
why is it not because you said child or
her body there's a big difference is it
a child i'm just using i'm trying to
understand where you're coming here
i don't think you're actually trying to
understand where i'm coming from well i
ask you could you understand where
they're coming from because i was four
people can you understand where they say
well it's a separate heartbeat so i
understand some kind of research but i
also think maybe they just aren't fully
knowledgeable on the entirety of
the texas bill that was passed for six
weeks before black people
yeah
maybe i don't know i don't know them i
didn't talk to but there are a lot of
americans who think there should be a
limitation you understand that your view
is considered you know there's extreme
left extreme right is no no abortions
even in the case of rape and incest
yours is abortion up until nine months
that's considered a pretty radical view
and so i'm curious to understand
where you draw and it seems to me like
you're
well statistically it's a raffle you
most americans don't agree with that
doesn't mean that it's right or wrong
i'm just saying it would be considered
very far left
what makes it acceptable and this is a
question that i'm really i am trying to
understand what makes it acceptable when
it's a baby that is totally viable
because that's what you brought up first
is completely viable outside of the womb
there's no debate at this point right
it's still connected to her body so it's
the umbilical cord can i bring something
up
the fetus is still relying on the
nutrients of her body to survive right
so it's her choice to in that pregnancy
so it is exclusively that a baby is
relying on the nutrients of the mother
because we both know the baby is relying
entirely on the mother's capabilities
well once for a year once the baby is
born and once it's um not connected to
that person then the baby's relying on
the mother's nutrients at that point
right mother's no it's not necessarily
not because of modern technology but for
a long time they had to be breastfed
they're still reliant upon the mother's
nutrients can i bring something up real
quick well not the mother that you don't
necessarily have to be the mother that
birthed the child to keep the child
alive
right but it's reliant upon the
nutrients of another woman you said it's
on reliance
what's difference between the the
now child breastfeeding versus the child
who is relying on the nutrients inside
the body
yeah um
well it's
the the hu the person that uh
had the child inside their body is
where am i going
uh we're uh we've been drinking but can
i bring something up
um
[Music]
you brought up the war on drugs earlier
and how it was ineffective because we
poured all this money into it and we uh
really heavily criminalized like drugs
and to like an extreme extent and it
never works actually made the problem
worse
uh if you read any white papers like any
research paper on abortion and like
limiting abortions
um no matter what your ideal of like how
conception or when it becomes a baby
abortions like throughout anywhere that
abortion's been criminalized
they still happen
but when you criminalize them then you
have the problems that we're facing
right now uh in the drug world it's
fentanyl and i've lost three friends in
two years from fentanyl but in abortions
it's going to be illegal abortions
because people are still going to be
desperate and still going to have them
and people are still going to die and be
like
armed now i'm old i won't be illegal i
now right now i'm 21 i can't afford to
have a child but
i if i were pregnant i couldn't afford
to have a child i would get an abortion
a safe
legal abortion
it would allow me to have a child in the
future because it's i
didn't have to harm my own body to abort
this child
right
so if a safe easy abortion legal
would ensure that i was able to have a
child in the future so why i don't
i don't understand the the question are
you asking me a question
no i'm just making a point okay because
i was still waiting i was just waiting
for the answer in the question regarding
the breastfeeding umbilical cord and i
understand you were talking about
fentanyl if you don't have abortions if
you're taking away safe legal abortions
then i
if someone has no choice and can't
afford
a child and i have a lot of i would
let's be honest about this it's just i
think i have a lot of choices you didn't
let me finish
so if
if it was not legal to have an abortion
and a person is still able to go out and
have what we call back alley abortion
could ruin their body for the rest of
their life they weren't it they want a
they're not going to be able to have a
child in the future because it
[ __ ] up their uterus
they you know it's
so a safe legal abortion would
ensure that that
child or that person
could have a child in the future
not necessarily
why
the the the correlation equaling
causation that a safe legal abortion and
there's of course the arguments we've
made that it's never safe for the baby
involved
but there are other choices that
wouldn't ensure anything because what
does ensure it is
contraception abstinence motherhood
adoption abstinence doesn't work
everybody knows that i think okay i gave
you three other options
can i tell you adoption i don't know
about you but there's never been a
single baby from people who haven't been
having sex yeah but we're all human and
everybody has sex and you try to teach
kids about absence like they taught us
in texas and it doesn't work and a lot
of people get pregnant when they're
young because they don't know anything
about contraception they get pregnant if
they
they're not practicing abstinence yes i
agree with you but who practices
abstinence are you going to be a monk do
you practice abstinence
i've written about it extensively yeah
probably practice it before i was
married yeah a lot of people do
[Music]
if you tell them to never have sex
well of course and a lot of people say
absolutely
the person or the child in high school
how to have safe sex
that's that's the whole point of that
i'm not advocating
i think i was pretty clear because i
brought up i brought up the other
choices
i don't really give a [ __ ] yeah
i don't know what your your point is
well you said can we wrap up the choice
of safe legal and rare abortion we're
just spiraling out of control we said
the choice of safe legal and rare
abortion would ensure
abstinence contraception motherhood
adoption abortion's not required to
ensure it you understand because you use
the word required
i'm sure you're aware that there are
states that are
making contraceptives illegal no i'm not
you're not aware of that there's no
multiple times there's no states right
now that make conscious definitely yeah
but you know they're trying to right
okay so now we've changed the goalposts
no no that's my that's literally what i
said
mississippi right now is uh talked about
how they're
making contraceptives illegal is not off
the board which is a pretty intense
thing to say
the state legislature mississippi has
not said that
what about louisiana
like can we bring it back and wrap it up
on whatever no i thought we just didn't
bring it back you brought it back to the
war on drugs that you were studying
human rights abroad and can't afford a
house and that's a human right and
internet and i think we've gone to a lot
of different directions where i wanted
to have a conversation about uh about
roe v wade yeah and i appreciate you
going these different directions you can
smoke if you want it's okay i think i
appreciate it though thanks for offering
um but uh i think i understand where you
guys line up on rovi and i think that
there's a divide in this country and you
know
states are going to be able to establish
their own laws my point is is i i mean
you're
not able to carry a child because i'm
assuming that you are a man without a
uterus why and oh okay because there's
stephen growling here because you're
[ __ ] stephen crowder and i know you
have a penis
oh well i don't never mind it doesn't
really you can show us real quick you
want to prove it no that's actually
that's a felony
we're okay with it we're consenting
sometimes the other people here are
concerned
if you can say that's the last thing i
want to see oh it's pretty big
you never got to see the doctor so maybe
uh yeah maybe it's because he lays it on
the microwave
so maybe because i'm a man i'll go with
it
because i'm a man i shouldn't have an
opinion on abortion right do you have an
opinion on murder theft arson come on
it's a silly argument you're going to
have an adventure we're all inside of
your opinion thank you man i appreciate
it i appreciate you guys have a good day
well there you have it we managed to
speak to the
view of the majority of americans on
okay abortion with some limitations the
radical 30 percent who don't believe in
uh any at all and um
this guy asked us for five dollars
and then he went and bought weed
so
i guess subscribe
what does weed go for
all right i'm going to level with you if
you liked this video
you have to hit the share button
um
otherwise your entire family will die i
don't write the rules i just call them
and this is clipped from the live show
every monday through thursday at 10 a.m
eastern that's the best thing you can do
to watch live i mean you know you didn't
you you ran a fall your family's dead my
family is dead but my mother left me
with this shirt before she went home to
meet the lord oh well i guess we all
come out winners